Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
Moco-chan!
We forgot to hide.
How about the trampoline?
Moco-chan, can you pull the trampoline?
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa!
I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians.
Today!
Today is the day.
Today is the 101st.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 101st episode!
BAU BAU!
Is that how you say it?
I'm gonna have a hard time saying it now.
101st.
Yeah, I'm not good at saying the bigger numbers.
102nd, I feel like it's easier.
101st sounds weird, right?
How are the 200?
That's two.
That's a lot of numbers.
BAU BAU!
Well, first off, Ruffians are maybe joining us today for the very first time!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
It's because we didn't bounce on the trampoline right away, Moco-chan.
Did you miss the trampoline that much?
Yeah, the trampoline is a very important part of our morning.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, did you hear that?
You have to start out your morning not just with FUWAMOCO Morning, but also the trampoline.
We're not worried about anything yet.
I'm worried about if there's gonna be a trampoline next time though.
BAU BAU!
Well, I have something for you to worry about, Ruffians.
A new morning!
Not a new morning.
It is a new morning, but that's not what they should worry about!
No.
I... Moco-chan.
Justice.
No!
They're coming... They're not going after the Ruffians.
Nobody needs to worry about them!
If you say it like that, then I'm convinced, Moco-chan.
Just like that.
Confidence!
But yes, Ruffians, you have to worry.
Why?
Because there's been bad news.
Bad news?
Like Shiori left all her snacks bad news?
No, not like that!
Biboo didn't get ice cream bad news.
There's been another peril sighting.
De-den!
Ruffians!
Your beloved as in- Wait!
Your beloved Nendoroids!
Wait!
What's going on?
Is- Is Pero splitting off into multiple different Pero's?
Or, uh, did- did Good Smile decide to bring out some really silly Pero face parts for some Nendoroids, or?
No.
I- I don't think they can do that, you know?
Um, I guess that makes sense.
But, why would they do that?
Why would they ever want to do that, huh?
So, then- Huh?
Huh?
Wait, so-
But this then, is Pero taking over our senpai's pets too?
You know, right?
Bubba is now... Plubba!
Boop is... Blero.
Can you see, Ruffian?
Right there, so tiny.
Wow.
I kinda like them.
Look at Korone-senpai, Okayu-senpai.
Kinda...
Kinda works, you know.
Pero's face strangely... It fits well, right?
Right?
But why though?
Pero-gami korone.
Pero-gami.
I don't like that.
Not at all.
No.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't think we need to think that deeply about it, Ruffians, but... Yeah.
We hope that your figures, maybe they return to their normal, cute, not nasty selves.
Nasty selves, no.
Just cute.
It's a very nice collection.
I know.
I can only dream of FUWAMOCO Nendoroids and figures one day.
She'll be excited, Ruffians.
Not as excited as us, Moco-chan.
That's always it.
BAU BAU!
Pero Sighting can be disappointing, but the next is not disappointing.
Ruffians, you might have noticed this, but maybe you didn't yet.
I don't know, has there been much information in English about it yet?
Maybe not.
But there's something called hololive City, and it was recently announced to be happening again this summer!
hololive City is back this year, 2024.
It happened last year with Tokyo Dome City, but this year it's expanded.
hololive City is now teaming up with multiple theme parks around Japan for an amazing club!
And you know what?
This time, us, us, FUWAMOCO, we're a part of it and we're representing hololive at Tokyo Dome City Attractions!
BAU BAU!
Aki-senpai, Torae-senpai, Aki-senpai, Suisei-senpai, Korone-senpai!
We're so excited!
Ruffians, this event is gonna be going on from August 1st to September 2nd!
That's a month.
But there'll be a bunch of special things going on.
There'll be collab goods, as well as collab attractions and rides, foods and drinks, stamp rally, minigames,
Even an escape game.
Escape game, huh?
Who knows what could be announced, huh?
Just lots of fun.
Yeah.
And while FUWAMOCO will be a part of the Tokyo Amusement Park, the Tokyo Dome City Attractions, there are also other parks all across Japan collabing with multiple senpais, so please check it out too!
No, especially if you're planning a trip to Japan any time this year.
Right?
Make sure to keep hololive CD in mind, okay?
It's the perfect time to check out Japan's best fun parks!
Right?
Yeah, not just, you know, the land with the mouse.
There's a lot of different fun parks, you know.
And actually, FUWAMOCO, when it comes to theme parks, like in Japan, we've only ever been to one called Space World!
Space World!
In Fukuoka.
Yeah.
It was a really fun time, but actually now it's closed.
So, you know, that means we have to go have fun at the fun parks while we can still have fun.
You know, be there for your oshi while you can.
You know, go have fun at the fun parks while you can have fun.
Yeah, we have to go explore lots of them, huh?
Especially Tokyo Dome City.
Yeah, we're looking forward to it!
BAU BAU!
And that's all we have for FUWAMOCO Morning, huh?
Ruffians.
Yeah, that's how we're gonna do things from now on.
Episode 101.
FUWAMOCO Morning ends by 810 AM.
Way more on time than we've ever been, huh?
Right?
Yeah.
Nothing more to mention.
That's it.
Out of news.
Right, Moco-chan?
Nothing mentionable.
Yeah.
No.
Nah!
That's not the case at all, right, Ruffians?
Yeah!
Yeah, because there's been some amazing news, big updates.
And, well, we talk a lot about BAU time and how time kind of passes funnily.
Funnily?
Funnily.
You know, because I see it really just feels just like yesterday.
That us and all of Advent, we just debuted, right?
Right!
But it's not!
We did not debut yesterday!
Yeah, you know, actually, we didn't debut yesterday, but it was announced!
hololive Justice, a brand new hololive EN generation, will be making their debut!
BAU BAU BAU!
It's not my debut.
No, no, no.
My debut happened 11 months ago.
Somehow, yeah.
But I'm so excited!
You know, we'll have four lovely hololive EN kohai.
Well, even though, you know, they're lovely and I'm sure that they will respect us lots as their senpai.
Right.
To be truthful, I haven't seen anything like that from them yet.
Yeah, you don't.
They're trying to catch us and put us back in the cell.
Huh?
No.
Ruffians!
We told you we're innocent puppies, right?
Innocent!
You know it, right?
We just got carried away.
We're having fun!
You know how it can be seriously silly sometimes, right?
Yeah.
It's just that.
Sure!
It's been 11 months, Ruffians!
We're innocent puppies!
Yeah.
We know that.
Puppies who are also demon-clad dogs take care of your spine.
Yeah, yeah!
First!
Well, we have... Elizabeth Rose Bloodflame.
BAU BAU.
She's their leader.
FUWAMOCO.
Actually, I'm more scared of her.
Yeah.
I don't like blood.
I don't like flames.
I don't like roses.
I do like roses.
That's okay.
But you know, she just has this aura when she speaks.
So commanding and... I don't know.
Melodic!
You know, we just become good puppies.
I mean, baby puppies.
I mean, good puppies.
We're always good puppies, right, Moco-chan?
I'm never a baby puppy.
But, you know, there was a good mention of some good manners.
And you know, FUWAMOCO, we like manners.
Good manners.
But, she's a bit proper.
Right?
Really don't want to get caught by her.
No.
Yeah.
We have to find a way to put her out.
Put out the flame.
No more fire fire.
No more lighting the fire for her.
Yeah.
But next!
We have Gigi Murin.
Oh my gosh.
She's such a grumbler.
She needs to calm down a bit, you know?
Not chase us around so much.
No!
Yeah.
Realize that no matter how hard she tries, we can smell a bad person's smell on her.
Can you smell it, Ruffians?
Yeah, she's not a dog.
No dog smells grumbly.
Yeah.
I wonder why she wears such a silly hoodie though.
Huh?
Maybe it's just a fashion statement, huh?
You can smell it too!
Yeah.
Okay.
What?
No.
BAU BAU.
And next, there's Cecilia Immergreen!
No.
She's a...
An automaton.
Follow me then.
A.K.A.
A robot doll or something.
Something else.
Yeah!
I really like sweet and cute me robots!
But I... Then she decided to hunt us down so I... I'm sort of past that now.
Hi.
Yeah.
But, you know, it looks like she does a lot more than just, like, bee-boops and those kind of things.
Bee-boops!
Bee-boops, not bee-boo.
Bee-boops.
Yeah.
She can also play the violin, maybe.
I guess that's pretty cool.
Right?
Yeah, but she won't get to us with that, though, right?
Right.
Right?
We won't be like, ooh, what's that beautiful music, right?
We would never be interested in music, right?
No.
It's not at all appealing to us.
And... Finally!
We have Raora Pantera!
She's really scary when she has her eyes on us.
But otherwise!
That tail!
I can't speak here, but that tail!
I wanna eat my mouth!
Thighs?
No.
No!
Tail!
Do you agree, Ruffians?
Ruffians!
Tail!
Yeah, it's the perfect snack!
Right?
Do you see how thick it is?
Juicy!
Tail!
Yeah!
Not if you're gonna look at her tails like they're a snack one.
We've been looking at hers.
Ruffians.
Her composites that she makes, they're really amazing.
A little bit too amazing though, no?
They could be a little bit more rough, you know?
That way, we're still cute, but maybe if it's rougher, we're not so identifiable.
Yeah, and nobody could tell who we are.
Right.
Yeah.
But, well, you know, Gigi smelt like a grumlin.
Raora, she has a very strong
Feline.
It's a good one.
A good one that we can tolerate.
Who knows?
But all I know is that all cats smell good no matter how much everyone might complain.
So, you know, I think that FUWAMOCO, we're probably gonna try and get a bite.
If we happen to cross paths again with her soon.
Maybe!
We could just use the pizza as a distraction, right?
That's our plan.
So I'll put it with the pizza.
Then the tail is ours.
Yeah!
Oh, it's like the circle of life!
Is it?
Cat eats pizza, dog eats cattail.
Huh.
Yeah, just like that.
Dog is happy.
Beautiful world.
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
And, well, you know, huh.
They're gonna be making a debut soon, right?
But!
Huh?
There's times!
It's a little surprising.
It's this weekend!
Their debut is coming up this big weekend!
They start at 8pm PT on Friday and Saturday.
And then there will be a big collab with all of them on Saturday at 9.30pm PT.
So you can see at the bottom of the graphic here.
But you absolutely won't want to miss it!
And...
Also right now, if you head over to Twitter, you can actually even get
BAU BAU!
Well, we hope that maybe you feel a little bit more energized
Moco-chan!
Wow.
Ruffians!
It's that time of the week again!
You know what time it is.
It's time for a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
Actually, this year, it's a bit of a different Pup Talk.
You know, this one is for our new holo and kohai that are debuting very soon.
You might have heard of them.
Justice!
Of course, if it applies to you two Ruffians, it's even better.
But anyways, Justice!
You may be bad guys still trying to catch us, but I know that won't ever happen.
So, instead, I'll have pity on you.
Is it still a pup talk or is it a pity party?
Anyways!
Doesn't matter!
Justice!
It's your big debut day this weekend!
It must still not feel real right.
It must be...
All sorts of emotions, you know, excited, happy, scared, nervous.
But don't worry!
Your debut will go perfectly.
Because ultimately, all you have to do is just be you.
Not anybody else, just you!
You're here with us now for a reason.
Believe in yourself and all the skills you've built up all this time.
You know,
It's sort of funny when you look back on all your experiences to see how many things have led up to now.
It's sort of silly how things work like that, huh?
And you know, if the debuts are too scary for you, just forget.
Forget about it.
Because after the debuts, what comes is lots of wonderful times with your newfound friends and audience on the debut.
It'll just be over before you know it.
So, enjoy it, okay?
Just have fun, and let's both work hard to make Holo-EN an even more wonderful and special place, okay?
You'll do amazing during your debut.
I know it for sure!
Let's all work hard together, okay?
BAU BAU!
Ganbatte ne!
I'm full.
Let's cheer for the MOTSUL KING!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I think we have another Doggie of the Day today, right Moco-chan?
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Clyde!
I guess he does look a bit tiny, but he's super powerful in his way.
I like that one.
Maybe he could outrun Gigi no problem.
Yeah, I'd like to be able to do that too.
We do our best, right?
He looks like a doll.
He's not a doll, he's a dog.
Doggie of the Day, not dolly of the day.
Yeah, well, apparently Cloud isn't the fluffiest one of us.
But he loves fashion!
Yeah!
Yeah, he's also a lazy fashionista.
Lazy one.
But that's because he likes to cuddle.
You can't fault him for that.
Yeah.
Hi.
Wow, Moco-chan!
Hi!
How does Cloud BAU BAU?
I think it's like... BAU BAU.
BAU BAU.
I can barely hear Cloud.
Very stylish, huh?
Dignified BAU.
Meow.
Is that his BAU BAU?
No!
That's me agreeing.
You know, a cloud could be a cloud and run as fast as he wants and be free in that beautiful blue sky there.
But no!
Instead, he decides, I want to wear this little jacket.
I want to be a bit of a lazy baby.
And I want to cuddle with you!
Be by your side.
Lazy baby.
I just want to be a lazy baby.
Sometimes we all want to be a lazy baby, right?
Sometimes.
BAU BAU!
It's not a bad thing.
No bullying!
It's not bullying!
We're not bullying flowers or tea.
No.
Yeah.
Well.
You've been going for walks, right?
Right!
It's the summer time!
I know it's hot, but the weather is nice.
Beautiful weather!
Right!
So let's take a walk.
Where have you been going for a walk today?
Today I went on a walk!
We have De-den!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
That's like a kind of green water, huh?
Right.
Is that a good thing?
Yeah, it's a beautiful beach.
But, you found some treasures there too.
A horse, a horseshoe crab shell?
A horse, a horse.
Not a horse, a horseshoe crab.
A full horse.
Horses on beaches too, right?
It could be possible.
And some pebbles too!
You know, that's the most... The best thing about just going for a walk is the little treasures that you find.
I'm just so happy that you had an amazing adventure!
And on a day with such great weather too!
I feel like I can hear the waves of the sound.
The waves of the picture.
I hope you enjoyed the beach a lot!
BAU BAU!
Next!
Ruffians, we got a question from you!
FUWAMOCO, what's the Question of the Day today?
De-den!
Hi Fuwawa and Mococo!
How are you?
We're feeling fluffy and fuzzy.
I have a question about your name.
Do you have a preference for how Ruffians write it?
FUWAMOCO!
FuwaMoco?
Fuwamoco?
'fuwamoco.'
FWMC FUWAMOCO.
'fwmc' fuwamoco.
Something else?
Does it not matter?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, what do you think is the best answer for this question?
We'll throw the question back at you!
I'm just curious.
Your answers aren't going to change the answer, huh?
FUWAMOCO.
FUWAMOCO!
FWMC FUWAMOCO!
Oh, I see.
It's a really good question!
FUWAMOCO!
We prefer 'FUWAMOCO' in all caps best, you know?
Yeah, and then if you're gonna shorten it... Shorten it, because sometimes you don't have enough letters.
Yeah.
'FWMC' in all caps too.
FUWAMOCO!
Right!
It's a good, it's a really good question.
We see all kinds of FUWAMOCO being written, but the one that makes us ahhh the most is FUWAMOCO!
With all caps.
How about 'MOCOFUWA'?
No.
Right, Moco-chan?
MOCOFUWA.
No.
It's like being put backwards, right?
I don't want a backwards headbutt, okay?
No.
Yeah.
'YOWAZAKO'?!
What are 'YOWAZAKO'?
Where's FUWAMOCO?
Who's that?
I don't know that.
Hi.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
#FWMCMorning, okay?
Don't think "my walk recently wasn't interesting."
"You know, I'm not gonna submit anything."
No, we're waiting!
You just have to take the photo and tell us what was the best part, okay?
Please, we're waiting, okay?
Please be a part of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, we have another stream coming up.
It's a bit of a busy time, but it's the next stream.
We have... FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians, you wouldn't even believe the kind of day we had today, and the day we had yesterday, and the day that we're gonna have tomorrow, and the day that we're gonna have the day after tomorrow!
Yeah.
These demon dogs are working like dogs.
And we're having a bunch of fun too.
We're gonna do our best and we'll see you next on Friday for FUWAMOCO Morning Desh!
But on schedule!
On schedule!
Yeah, so next we have homework day.
But after FUWAMOCO Morning we have Keep Talking and Nobody Explodes.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
And then, after the last advent collab, we're gonna play some Suika game and chat all together with you, our friends!
There may be some changes in the time here, so we hope that maybe you'll be able to stay up late.
Stick around with us a little bit after a bunch of exciting things happening!
Yeah.
That'll make us very happy.
Just a bit of a heads up then.
Yeah.
The next day we're gonna work really hard!
Hard!
Big, big hard work day for us!
Yeah.
It'll make us really happy to be able to see you and chat with you.
A little bit more time.
Yeah.
And fill up our Ruffian batteries before we head off on a big day!
And that's our schedule!
Thank you, Ruffians!
And for the Ruffians who are joining us today through the archive, here is your FUWAMOCO with its BAU BAU justice!
BAU BAU!
The trampoline is not here, but the jingle is going multiple times higher.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for the 101st episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Jingu!
BAU BAU!
Felixburger.
Cyborg.
BAU BAU!
Jelly Pot.
Thomas.
BAU BAU!
Delta.
Link.
BAU BAU!
Kevin Lopez.
Princey Anne.
BAU BAU!
Pygram.
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!